president joe biden's last positive
coveted test again
uh confined him to the white house for
the second time in the last two weeks
earning him the sympathy of many who are
sending the sideline leader get what
wishes including the press
former president who dashes off a doozy
of a sympathy note on sunday joe biden's
second bout of kovitz sometimes referred
to as china virus was sadly misdiagnosed
by his doctors
he instead has dementia but is happily
recovering well joe is thinking of
moving part-time to one of those
beautiful wisconsin nursing homes where
almost 100 percent of their residents
miraculously and for the first time in
history had the strength and energy to
vote
even if those votes were cast illegally
get well soon
where was i
wait where was this posted where was his
question and how that is so freaking how
many issues just those many words i
thought it was banned from twitter
no that's true this is true
bro how funny again his message will get
out it doesn't matter where people will
come okay okay pap honest to god you
think okay listen it's funny it kind of
sounds like him you think he really
that's per as a comedian that is
freaking hilarious it's misdirection
he's kicking his ass on four different
points and then and then he's still
putting in the illegally vote and he
goes get real soon
that's just brilliant trolling bro like
hate him like how hilarious is that
that's a really good written joke that's
hilarious
[Music]
it's you know you know what it is it's
like the the breakfast what is the
breakfast thing they do uh when the
president gets up there and they say
cuss like they're making fun of
themselves what is that thing called you
know the washington correspondence
he says you know uh earlier uh hillary
uh was walking around and you know she
bumped into me
and uh she said pardon me and i said
i'll think about it
it's good
that's brilliant that's brilliant and
and then hillary gets up and she says
look i i you know it's always great to
have a uh a person that came out of new
york a strong personality a businessman
a billionaire
uh let's make some noise for uh mayor
bloomberg who's in the house here with
us
yeah oh my god it's the best one to go
back and forth but listen as much as
this was probably written by somebody
else it was inspired by only one person
donald j trump like if if if joe biden
sent a tweet like this you wouldn't even
laugh because you're like first of all
joe you would never in your life say
something like that okay because he hit
look look at all the points so here he
hit kovid being the china virus that
they all you know science was wrong yeah
right then he goes say he does have
dementia but he's hoping he's doing good
and then he goes all those people in the
home that actually voted for the first
time that they got the strength to go
out and vote well that's just come on so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]